and then it's like okay now we're ready
why isn't it happening yeah yeah like we
did everything by the book we wanted to
have a stable job we wanted to have
enough income to have security and have
a house have the relationship of the
marriage that we have in the support
system that we have and everything was
ready and then we're like okay where's
the baby when is the baby coming yeah
so what what is the what's the IVF
process like because that's what you
guys are doing right yes IVF is in
simple terms having a baby through
science okay so it's called in vitro
fertilization it's a process of
injecting myself with a lot of shots to
give me hormones to grow my eggs farming
farming am I usually farming farming and
farming her eggs so every month you have
you release an egg but when you do shots
you farm like 10 20 30 eggs so the
ovaries usually this big mm-hmm they
become one shake she's farming they grow
to the size of a grapefruit what da [ __ ]
yeah cuz one egg could fit in this right
like a ping-pong yeah imagine then you
have 15 eggs cuz you have two ovaries 15
eggs on each side and so each ovary she
was wearing my pants at one point yeah I
couldn't fit into my own clothes I look
like I was pregnant but I wasn't yeah
that's how big her ovaries like god only
[ __ ] baby go under anesthesia and
then they surgically remove the eggs and
then they put it into a petri dish with
his sperm and they try to grow and them
into embryos and then when they grow
into embryos you have to wait for day
three day five and see they're viable
embryos and then you transfer it back
into me in hopes of implanting and then
you grow a human being yeah [ __ ] Jesus
that's [ __ ] crazy in my mind I didn't
know that it expanded or anything like
that I just thought it was like a little
egg like a little little salmon roe it
is it is cuz I think at maturity it's
like 20 centimeters mm-hmm I mean I'm
about 20 millimeters yeah 20 centimeters
like that what 20 millimeters
and so yeah maturity there they're like
little seminaries so imagine you have 30
of them mm-hmm holy [ __ ] right that it
gets pretty big that that surgical
process is that very painful you don't
really feel anything you just go under
but we had a really bad experience the
first time I almost died
really I almost died no but what
happened was she you could tell the
story cuz I wasn't in the room with her
I think I you son of a [ __ ] oh yeah
waiting room outside I think I would
have reacted for sure though so they put
me under well before they put me under
and the doctor was like hell is your
alcohol tolerance and I was like I think
it's pretty good because I think I'm
like my dad like I could drink a lot
without getting drunk cuz I was like I
think it's pretty good and so she gave
me I was like but I haven't drink in a
while so I'm not sure and then she gave
me a huge dose of what do you call it
was something probably is some kind of
some drug some drug to make me go under
but it was so strong that my heart
stopped beating and so you hear yourself
flatline and then I see it I hear the
doctor shaking me and saying breathe
breathe breathe breathe wake up wake up
breathe breathe and I was like like my
life life just flashed before my eyes
and I was like [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ]
die yeah and then she was like shaking
me shaking me and I was like trying so
hard to force myself to breathe and then
I suddenly started breathing again and I
could hear my heartbeat again and then
after that she's like okay I'm not gonna
give you any more drugs we're just gonna
start the retrieval process and I was
awake the entire time so I like I felt
like pressure I felt like were that
uncomfortable and then that retrieval
was actually very difficult because they
didn't retrieve any eggs successfully so
it was a bust so I went through all that
just again nothing at the end and then
when I came out to the waiting room and
the doctor told me that I she didn't get
anything and that it was a failed
retrieval I just burst into tears no it
was like why does this keep happening
to us and I told him about what happened
and he was furious and he's like
thinking about suing her he's thinking
about taking action he's thinking about
so many things that could have gone
wrong and he that was I mean we were
like maybe we should take a break
yes he told me he's like I don't want to
lose you in this process of trying to
have a baby
yeah so that kind of hit me and I was
like that's true like I don't want our
marriage to be you know the in the place
where he was and going through all this
and then risking my life to try to have
this baby
yeah it's the weirdest thing because
you're it's like this thing that you're
trying to work towards but at the same
time you don't want to work towards yeah
cuz the resemble it's the ultimate price
to pay like it is it worth it mmm is it
worth it and and I think at the time I
was so furious but at the same time it
was like she wasn't ready to fight yeah
cuz like she was devastated after that
yeah and I was like wow but I want to I
want to do something about the situation
but she was like she just feels so
shitty and and she wants to like just
isolate herself in like she's just this
weird balance it wasn't like we were in
sync at that time because she just gone
through what she's been through and it's
not only that it's like the hormones too
that you have to inject yourself with it
make you crazy crazy
oh really crazy yes imagine PMS every
month I don't know Muriel has PMS and
she's oh she does does imagine what she
goes through every month at the worst
time in like 10 times that not just it's
not that straightforward - it's like all
right so like when we were in China I
remember this vividly because you know
at that time a month yeah she's she's
counting the days she's timing the
window yeah it becomes very romantic and
it's time right and all right one thing
about that I think nobody wants to get
here in their marriage where it's like
oh it feels like routine now if you yeah
that's planned it feels like oh right
now it's optimal so now we got to do it
doesn't matter what we're doing we got
to do this yeah
so in China there was this one moment
where she was taking some medication for
it and it's the weirdest thing because
she's like she's like in the mood mmm
but she's also in the mood to kill me
you know so she's like me now before I
kill you
yeah she's like hey it's time and then
oh and at this time we were late he's
lying he's died yeah we we were at her
parents place so she's like yeah get
quiet though
and so her parents like right next door
the other row noise and then so you know
cool like we're trying and we're trying
and it's like she crosses over from in
the mood don't want to kill you I was
like I can't go any faster like I have
to be quiet I you know I'm a conscious
yeah and then on top of that it's like
it's not our bed because I'm not used to
knowing where it squeaks and where it
does not like conscious about that too
and then she's like oh yeah that's gonna
make him calm oh my god Anna what the
[ __ ] because it not only that it was
late so he had stuff planned the next
day and it was like oh I can't just
hurry up yeah and like the deaths there
yeah helping either he's going limp he's
like don't you [ __ ] dare get
something to keep that [ __ ] rock-hard
yeah so that was like one of my memories
like first memories of us trying and
trying to do it abroad and in China
because we we saw the doctor here but we
brought the medicine with us and yeah
it's just you know honey you threaten
him and [ __ ] him at the same time and
expected this relationship you're like
enjoying it on you
like okay [ __ ] baby
I'm like we're not gonna make a baby you
don't come well that's how to make you
happy it wasn't hard enough [ __ ]
somebody who's angry I said just staring
at them with [ __ ] anger and [ __ ] did
I get blinking hi [ __ ] blink it wasn't
like it was a now or later usually come
in a minute all you had to do was just
[ __ ] give them a hands it and right
before you stick it right in really it's
so much pressure like holy [ __ ] did like
I would just I would just be clammy the
whole time yeah you're thinking that and
yeah it's like all the excitement lead
for the room and then you're like cuz
the moment like Mariel you'll see Mariel
gets angry at me all sex I've got ya you
are disgusting to me like you get the
[ __ ] away from me disgust stinks drives
out the window yeah it's just like she's
just like what are you doing I'm looking
bad suddenly you're dude can you turn
yourself into a man [ __ ] wave you get
a lot of pressure though yeah and it's
it's hard I think like I think like the
maybe the difficult part especially for
you is you know that situation where you
see your wife almost passed away just
because of you know it's like you're
almost you're giving like to take a life
right yeah it sucks because you see her
going through this process and it's also
something it's also across that you
can't bear for her right so you just sit
on the sidelines well it's it's tough
too because I think it's we're on
different pages she's willing to do that
yeah to trade a life for life yeah oh my
my perspective is we existed before this
baby even in the picture mm-hmm so I
don't know if I'm willing to trade off
and lose you to have a baby yeah cuz you
know this conversation pretty often
you'll ask me are you willing to risk
your life for this Tevez baby yeah and I
always say yes because in order to go
through IVF to put yourself through that
emotional and physical
Payne you have to want it that badly
yeah the ribs are high for sure it's not
for everyone mm-hmm because that's such
a man that's something I think I didn't
even think about it like that because I
guess like I would be in your situation
to where I'm like him I had to lose like
I told Mary I was like listen there's a
couple of options this worldly you leave
me I'll kill myself you die I'm killing
myself because I can't start this all
over again this for five years why are
you [ __ ] crazy like I'm not gonna
find somebody else again I even
mentioned this two or two I was like hey
if I died would you would you get with
somebody else and she goes well I don't
know like that's the future I'm like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I would just stay single
for the rest of my life it's just too
hard for me it's just too hard for me to
rebirth at some point it seemed like
it's just too much yeah like I'd rather
cuz I was fine being by myself before
her and she was the bonus in my life so
I can go back to being by myself right
right it's completely okay I don't need
to attach myself emotionally to somebody
else and go through the learning process
all over again like if you die I'm done
[ __ ] like this is this like I I might
date flirt around [ __ ] around a little
bit but they're not coming to my house
this is still to me it'll be still this
is still our house right yeah and would
they be okay like I'm married to
somebody else and I visit your [ __ ]
grave every year you know I mean would
they be okay with that [ __ ] cuz that's
gonna be a little odd for me because I
don't know if I could do